Nêm bà thống người, phụ năng lượng của quả nè cho biết đã ghi nhận các lượng nổ bản một số cơ sở nấn lượng
lắp biệt là tại các cơ sở hạ tâm cận chuyển khi đó bảo sản sống từng ngày.
Công tin ở lượng cua ra nắp của gà sở biệt, đây là lượng tâm cận lượng nhất bảo cơ sở hạ tâm sả xuất khi đó của cộng tin ngày kể từ tháng 2, năm tháng 2, hạ hạ.
Mặc dụng ngà cho đứng gà, nát trình giệm cho các đợt tâm công, tuy nhiên hạ tinh tà sở hạ tâm tin bộ cua phòng ngà cho biết
lượng vũ trang ngà trước đó đã phát động một cuộc tấn công lượng vàng vụ khi tâm xa,
với độ chính xác cao của tâm đất trên không bỏ trên biển.
Cúc nhiều mại bài thông người lấy vào tổ hợp mục tiêu chứa sát điện.
Cúng trong ngày 4 tháng 1, hóa đông điểm miếng cho OAU đã quy định ra hạn các biển thác hạn chế,
nhanh vào dựng caan nhân và tổ chức liên quan đến ngà thêm 1 năm,
tức là định ngày 1 chiến tháng 1, năm 2, hạy 2,